軋空股怎麼挑
很多人呢放空
會放空在這地方
到這裡含淚回股
做股票
切記啊
你要活到最後
不要為了面子而爭
所以我會教你
如何避免賠掉這一錢
你看到券支比飆高
沿著上軌
主力買超
這三大條件
話不多說
坐上車
等人家軋上去
又有火箭帶你升空來
來料來了
嘿嘿
賺跑下車
小哥最近街頭
浓浓的
萬聖節位
你居然接得住這個梗
你這個年紀會過萬聖節嗎
我剛剛去住飯店回來而已
我最近都在住台北的飯店
台北的飯店超便宜
超便宜
兩三千塊五星級酒店
然後現在的裝潢
它現在的氣氛
都放很多南瓜
跟這個一樣啊 對不對
沒錯啊
所以萬聖節就是群魔亂舞的時候
對 沒錯
最近做個票有這種感覺
做個票有這種感覺
那你今天要交一點不一樣的
要交一點從來沒交過的
應景萬聖節Party
你沒有給糖我不太想交
蛤 什麼什麼 你說什麼
不給糖就不交
你三歲小孩啊
來 姐姐給你糖
好 就拿
快點給我交
欸欸欸欸
太多了
今天好不好
姐姐有多少糖
你就要教多少東西
好不好 那我今天把特別的
幹什麼小哥當三歲小孩
我有準備
我把特別的留在最後面講
今天有帶一個武林秘籍
對 沒錯
聽說是一檔個股
對 好
今天呢
群魔亂舞
我們要配什麼咧
小哥從來沒教過的秘技喔
可能今天會有一點點進階
我們拿我們的點閱率拼了好不好
叫做什麼
其實小哥發現最近有一個東西
很磨很妖
是什麼勒
嘎空喔
現在會有什麼嘎空嗎
現在還真的很多嘎空
為什麼 因為大家都以為啊
台股在高檔盤整一段時間對不對
又要沒選了對不對
一定是接下來行情會大跌
所以現在的融券增加很多喔
偏偏有些股票
不告訴你
給你搗蛋喔
你月空它
他就嘎到你爆炸
所以今天小哥要教我們
就是嘎空股怎麼挑對不對
對
好 最近真的有這種嘎空升天的嗎
真的有啊 真的有蠻多的
好 我們來看一下這個
為什麼會有嘎空呢
為什麼咧
首先 這個很多人放空
會放空在這地方
後面呢
到這裡寒淚回補
不是 我放空
當然是覺得他已經飛太高
飛太遠了
我要把它空下來啊
他怎麼會空在起漲點
一開始可能覺得他這個基本面不好
漲的有點多 他就去空
空在 例如說10塊漲到20塊
就漲蠻多了嘛 漲一倍了
結果20塊去空 就嘎到40塊
那這個他就變成藍料了
因為他在底下是先龍券賣出的
那後面被迫含淚回補
可能很多人現在還不太懂
什麼叫龍券賣出啊
什麼叫含淚回補
但是先看案例
嘎工長得才兇
對 好 來看最近最兇的
陸海啊
對啊 我超幾百年前
我拜訪
我拜訪過
你有拜訪過
做貨運的對不對
對對對
然後在一些大型機具的
對 我拜訪過這家公司
最近飆翻了
飆翻了
你看一下
這個世紀還沒賺錢
對
沒有賺錢的股票
重點呢 籌碼又爛
欸 小哥
籌碼爛就是你不喜歡的啊
對啊
這種很多看籌碼的喔
會被他嘎
喔 像你
有被他嘎一點點
有嘎必報
所以這種喔
被嘎的時候就要趕快停損
喔
可是你看籌碼爛
你應該很有信心繼續空啊
不行
因為你不曉得這座山呢
的山頂在哪邊
股價呢會像一座山
那我們做股票呢
最忌諱的
就是去摸頭
所以基本上你有紀律設定
可能你現在已經虧多少
就還是砍掉
對 空了 絕對快下來
對
這個被咬 趕快砍掉
那這個像基本面爛
谷魚來也不會買
籌碼面爛 你來也不會買
他在咬誰啊
他可能被某些社團
對
或某些老師
又來
常例推薦
對
導致主力是在出的
是
但是社團跟老師
讓信仰會讓股票一直漲
信仰股
所以他最近很強
那你看一下這個龍卷
龍卷很可憐
在這裡被嘎上去了
但是小哥等一下會教我們對不對
這種信仰股可以破解嗎
不要被他嘎到
好 那再來還有沒有別的例子
還有
來看最近也很厲害的
太陽能
太陽能真的很強
這個就恐怖了
我們有一集叫古瑜來講太陽能有沒有
對啊 看現在被他夢到了
對啊 那時候我都覺得說
市場股票籌碼不太好
結果後面還開布林
開布林啊
我們在布林通道那一集有講
所以通常空單看到開布林
趕快投降
對
開布林不管籌碼好不好
先投降再說
對 我們都會說做股票
這個切記啊
你要活到最後
不要為了面子而爭
好 所以這一檔呢
也嘎嘎
原因是什麼咧
你看一下
他也是一個沒有賺錢的公司對不對
你看這個卷資比後面好高啊
對
融券一路的賣
這一路賣一路嘎
一路賣一路嘎
為什麼
這個很多融券就是他漲很多啊
對
因為你看一下
這個從低點算上來啊
他今年大概漲了四五倍以上
對
好 所以其實融券看他不順眼
也是有道理啊
基本面又沒有好
然後又漲那麼多了
而且籌碼也不好
所以小哥你要來解貨啦
那我要怎樣
我才會看到那麼多爛的
我還上車去搭一波順風車
我今天就要教各位
這個從細項來教
好
所以我們先來解釋一下
什麼是龍券
什麼龍券
龍券
不是龍捲
也不是龍捲
是龍券
龍券
那农券是向券商借股票来卖
向券商借股票来卖
好 那第二个呢
农券时机呢
预计未来股价会下跌
当然啦 我就是说难听点看不爽它
那我们最好
我有太多被嘎的经验
所以我们都说
这个来商科学很幸福
因为我赔过太多这种钱
所以我会教你如何避免赔掉这些钱
甚至搭上車嘛 對不對
那這種呢 你記得喔
你真的要放空的時候
最好的時機是在月線下彎之後
好 月線下彎之後再去放空
會比較安全 弱勢股
但是一般人都喜歡去空強勢股
因為就是看他一直長很討厭啊
對啊 然後強勢
我完全明白那心情
對啊 強勢股又有很多隔日蔥進來
嗯
他就覺得 隔日蔥會賣
結果隔日蔥還真的賣了
就明天是一個大妖怪進來大買
完蛋了
一個大外資進來大買
龍券的陳述
好 那龍券陳述呢
這個上市櫃是9成 對
自備9成 所以槓桿大概是1.1倍
對 槓桿其實蠻低的
對 比農資小很多
對 小很多
那嘎起來很恐怖
嘎起來很恐怖
對啊 你有可能空100塊
他可以嘎到400塊
哈哈哈哈
哇 賠掉3 4倍資金這中間要挺損吧 太可怕了很恐怖喔所 這個做空其實是蠻難的對 我也覺得但我年輕時 就兩年前
我也喜歡做空
那現在呢
現在喔 因為就年長兩歲了
就比較喜歡做多
對 我覺得做多還是比較安全
好
那我們來看這個農圈放空的優缺點
好 有哪些優缺點
第一個 見空優點
第一个 下跌速度通常比上涨速度快
其实这个是有一个像蔡森老师
他也喜欢做空
因为下跌赚得快
对 下跌效率好
对 没错
所以你放龙卷很快
可能这个报酬率每天多10%
10%很快
对
像前阵子的妈妈股
你还记得吗
第二股
我们在前面节目有讲
是
說這些媽媽喊的股票
你們不要再買了 很恐怖
你不是已經改成全鎮小媽了嗎
沒有啦 沒有
要小哥好
那些媽媽 哇 這個社團裡面
拼命罵
討論區裡面一直來罵
說這個叫人家在六七十塊一直買
對
那結果呢 一下子就得到剩30塊
很快耶 對
預價買100多% 現在20%
聽了都想放空啦
下跌賺得快啊
對 很快
那第二個呢
幫助平衡多單部位
避開系統性大跌的風險
這就是避險對不對 避險
對 我們都要說
你要避開系統性大跌的風險
什麼叫系統性大跌的風險
就是美國選舉後結局出乎意料
台股跟著大崩盤
來 我問你
你猜誰當選會大跌
我覺得拜登
你覺得拜登喔
我覺得選不出來會大跌
我看你這個烏鴉子會不會成真
大家記起來
你下個禮拜看會不會選不出來
好喔
那但是勸空也有缺點
缺點啊
缺點太多了
有太多了
在台灣做空啊
沒人權
真的是沒人權
來看第一個
會強制回補
是啊
光這就煩了
光公司要整你都來不及了
對對對
什麼時候強制回補呢
股東會
除先席
而且隨便臨時召開股東會
也要回補
嗯 對
好 第二個呢
標借風險
對
標借風險呢
這個有的是倦源不足造成
沒有倦
看他很爛
也要跌了 沒有倦
喔 沒有倦
這個標倦是這樣喔
譬如說你空好了
嗯
結果漲上去了嘛
對啊 被嘎了
你想說我忍一下好了
我晚一點再停損
對
結果漲上去之後
融資跑了
欸欸欸
融資跑掉了
那就造成勸員不足
你的影響員就打電話跟你講
不好意思啊
今天有標借費
聽到這個都冷了你知道嗎
都冷了 標借費用
多少錢啊
每天像開獎一樣
你也有在付啊
對 我蠻常付的
還付過9萬塊
一聽到9萬
明天二話不說全部回補
不完了
這個遊戲不能玩下去
第三個呢
獲利有限
因為下跌呢
腰斬已經跌很慘了嘛
跌個剩下10%也很慘了
對 總不能跌到下市
對啊 那你頂多也賺個幾%
頂多賺個80%就很多了
對
我融券最多賺過90%
哦 那麼厲害啊
搞到倒了這樣
那個後面已經要下市了
對 賺過90%
對 可是你就不能像融資一樣
對
你融資你可以賺個200% 300% 400%
上涨其实是无限的
10块涨到1000块都可以
龙卷到98已经人生成就了
对啊 再多也没什么办法啦
那风险无限
恐怖啦
不是 小哥你听起来还蛮爱做空的耶
可是你现在讲完之后
好像在叫大家不要做空
痛 做空 痛
对 好
我们做空会有一些痛
做空会有一些快感
是 它咬起来真的蛮痛的
真的喔
所以你现在跟古鱼看起
死多頭嗎
他不錯啊
永遠都不痛
資券都不開的
資券不開我覺得是這種
所以做空風險大
但是我們可以找被軋空的
也是一種做多啊
我們來淋虐空頭是不是
常常你被淋虐的滋味
被淋虐之後反過來
淋虐別人
變成一個心理變態
太變態了
好啦 那這個
最怕的就怕被軋
所以剛剛有講說
可能放空比較危險
不如來做軋空股
對
怎樣的股票被軋空
好 我們來找一下
三大軋空條件
好
第一個
股價沿著布林上軌上漲
所以他很強勢
沿著我們交過的布林通道的上軌
一路漲上軌
只要沿著布林上軌
不要看籌碼了
不要管他
不要看籌碼
以前我們都看籌碼
主力賣超
對
賣很兇
那我來空他一下
他說不要看
因為現在主力很壞
他們現在知道
你有在看籌碼K喔
我把主力搞成賣超給你看喔
有在看歌有籌必報
對 有時候主力會很壞
你要小心啦
所以意思是股價還很強勢
他沿著布林的上軌道上漲的時候
即使籌碼差 基本面差
都不要空他
我們說股價像一座山
山的左邊不要空
空在山的右邊
好 看空間右邊比較安全
好 第二個呢
有分點主力 波段買進
等於籌碼上還可以的
對 對不對
你只好看到有波段買進的
對 放棄
有那種短線客的還可以
波段買進的不要
好 第三個資爭 勸真
這個叫火拚喔 火拚
融資也增加 融券也增加
做多的跟你做空的再火拚了
資深圈就在火拚了
券吃比飆高
但是為什麼兩邊火拚會造成軋空呢
因為這樣看起來是空頭輸啦
因為這個券啊
在往上軋的過程中
心裡會受不了
那可是我融資往下跌
我也會受不了才對啊
這個軋空就在往上漲的時候
對
那往下跌
你只好看到融資開始有點退了
對
那這個代表他這個軋空也快要到盡頭了
哦
軋空盡頭有一些徵兆
我們待會再跟各位講
所以現在兩派火拼
但是股價可能是往上漲的
那這個券就危險了對不對
對 券就危險了
那券之筆怎麼算
好 券之筆怎麼算
教你呢 這券之筆呢
我們就用融券的張數
對
除以融資的張數
非常好 很簡單
很簡單
除而已
對啊 很簡單
例如說
農券30張
農資100張
對
券日比呢就30%
喔 好
那券日比呢
只要大於30%
對
30%就很多囉
就很多了
因為放空人比較少對不對
對
因為30%應該這樣講
這個我們有各大券商
對
元大 群益 凱基
各大券商
那有的農資呢在元大
對
有的農券呢
可能在群益啊
群益的券可能多一點
對
他的資質可能稍微少一點
那有可能群的這個券呢
他就容易被嘎
喔 好
所以會有這個問題啦
所以一般來講30%就很多了
好 30%就很多囉
那大於30% 第一個有嘎空機會
對
第二個最討厭的 有標界機會
來看一下
這個我在市場上看過最恐怖的
嘎空
好
漢訊
哇
太恐怖了
這一檔
我對他一直說不出來的一個感覺
他曾經是鴻海集團概念股對然後每一次都有人說這檔有點腰對然後他就一直從很年輕腰到現在對
太腰了
太奇妙了
太恐怖了
你看年初2017年
年底的時候在多少
年底才69塊
對
然後嘎到4月變420塊
天啊 這真的太腰了
六倍
這是最恐怖的
就是從年底開始嘎
而且因為他過去累積了不少的黑粉
因為就是有點腰
所以那些黑粉都看他不高興
但是就是被嘎爆
對 然後這個往上漲過程中
其實非常恐怖的
他有多恐怖你知道嗎
多恐怖
例如說你在這邊放空
你在這邊放空喔
我都已經
我漲三根去空你可以吧
漲三根的喔
三根漲停板
你知道第四根怎麼嘎你的嗎
怎麼嘎
你漲三根去空
對
第四根開盤8%
跳上去8%
直接嘎爆你
8%他就問你
要補嗎
要不要補啊
要不要補
很補喔
你那個龍圈要不要回補
對
一開盤8%讓你想一下
5分鐘之後
所掌停
所掌停沒得補了
沒得補了
昨天我空第三根了
想不到今天我又再嘎一根
變賠10%
忍耐一下
我才不信
再撐一下
隔天再8%
没报我
我要补
再忍耐一下
又所长停
小哥
你来讲你自己吧
这几个
莉莉在目
我应该喊嘴眼泪讲这个
很恐怖的
莉莉在目
真的很恐怖
后面已经到怎么样
到被处置了
关门了
被处置了
继续长
關門 厲害
放狗 還是漲
這非常厲害
不過我覺得今年的關門股都要炸了
很少數跌 大部分好像都漲
對 今年年初一堆啊
今年年初一堆生技股都關門了
像最近太陽能股被關門的也是漲
它算比較OK的喔 先跌後漲
因為太陽能股它這個
現在只是5分鐘而已
年初一拖拉股 20分鐘
20分鐘 很要
那這個後面你看一下
他從60幾塊一直嘎到這一天420
哇 小哥你還在車上嗎
早就停損了
對 車上還得了
這個你有一倍資產
會嘎到讓你賠掉三倍
好 可是他的條件就符合剛剛小哥講的嗎
勸之比真
對 然後主力有破斷買進嗎
主力你看一下 主力在這裡都愛買
對 那股價有沿著布林上軌嗎
有 這裡沿著上軌
等一下 那你為什麼不聽話
有啊 有啊 後面就停損了
後面就停損
有停損啊
都符合你自己列的
沒有停損你也看不到我了
我們來看一下這個後面
來看這裡 這裡太恐怖了
你知道這420塊怎麼來的嗎
怎麼來的
你先來看一下這個卷資比
卷資比在這裡
這邊已經歸零了
歸零了歸零了
你知道為什麼卷資比歸零嗎
因為空軍死光了
不是 因為強制回補了
強制回補了
不補也得補
為什麼補啊 為什麼補
這個強制回補
因為股東會前兩個月
要強制回補
然後呢
你看喔 在強制回補前一天
強制回補前一天大紅K
你知道為什麼嗎
因為那天所有空軍就在那天含著眼淚補
集體投降
集體被怎麼樣
被尬在最高點
420塊
沒有 420塊是隔天
前天在410幾塊
隔天呢
開盤420
你知道這隔天開盤怎麼來的嗎
怎麼來的
因為最後一天還有人說
我就是不補
你叫我補 我還是不補
這還是可以
強制回補日那天你可以不補
反正會被強制嘛
你不補別人幫你補
隔天一找
券商幫你回補
就回補在
420塊
漢訊的人生最高點 420
這是空軍最慘最慘的一個案例
是
這個是只花4個月
對
漲了6倍
而且是小哥血雨淚的一堂課
中間參與了一小段
好恐怖啊
哇 難得
其實小哥你這個經驗難得
因為你都是秀隊帳單
賺多少賺多少賺多少
我們陪的都會講
但是這個真的是
嘎到真的是很有感
很有感
連每一個細節都記在心裡
比失戀還難過
所以
真的很痛的
所以後面呢
後面只要一嘎停損
認輸不完
好 可以吧
不完 不完可以吧
好 對
但也見證了嘎空股很兇
對
所以如果坐上車的人
那就是反過來賺三倍囉
對
好
所以呢 各位啊
這種車要怎麼坐
對
年初的時候最好坐
年初的時候
現在快11月了
快要年底了
我們這節目就教你
你要年初了
對 以後到年底了
到年初了你就去看一下
看網路上有沒有誰看哪一檔股票
最不爽的
你看到卷資比飆高
沿著上軌 主力買超
這三大條件
話不多說
坐上車
等人家嘎上去
坐上車又有火箭帶你升空
燃料來了
年初這種股票最多
所以在一個多月我們就有得做
就中股票了
好
那最近還是有啦
還可以舉例的
還是有
不過最近這個主力就沒那麼厲害啦
好
最近這個主力
剛剛講的嘛 媽媽股
媽媽股 美德一
美德一有個缺點
他跟剛剛漢遜不大一樣
他主力是在賣超
對
所以這個搭上去之後呢
各位看一下 在高點
對
之前融圈沒什麼空喔
到了這裡 融圈才開始大空
對
對 農券一開始有空
不過一下子就停損了
對
後面在高檔做頭的時候
農券開始大空 主力大賣
這種我們叫做高檔主力農券放空
好 高檔主力農券放空
厲害了 厲害
這是厲害的人進來空 沒錯
然後厲害的人看到討論區那些
媽媽 韭菜們
韭菜韭菜
那些閃戶韭菜們
一張不賣 奇蹟自來
通常看到這八個字呢
崩盤保證
因為這八個字走信仰路線
這八個字出現了
這股票都有弄一本
是
那這個美德一呢
就連續多少
連續八根
大跌
到第九根
也是大跌
連九根很弱
是
他叫軟九天
好
但是這個就是他真的可以去放空的股票
這種放空
獲勝的速度非常的快
非常快
很快
所以你只好看到高檔融券大增
對
主力是大賣的
主力進來空了
可是這就叫真正的放空股
對
它就不是軋空股了
像DR兩檔都這樣
兩檔你看喔
在高檔都是主力賣超喔
對
高檔融券大增喔
這都是厲害的主力
是
那後面就跌斷
好
所以小哥其實在教我們辨別
有的股票是軋空股
我剛剛講的可能也不應通道上去
主力還有在波段買進等等的那些徵兆
但有一些就不要誤以為
他叫軋空股還傻傻還在車上
他真的要大跌了
對 沒錯
好
所以我們要特別注意軋空的時間
好 剛剛有講囉
對
最常出現的時間太棒了 要來了
要來了
對 所以年底的時候
你就記得看卷之比高的
對
記得去討論去看一下
有沒有人在鼓吹放空的
嗯
有鼓吹放空的
那都是準備要往上漲囉哈哈哈鼓吹做多的就是準備往下跌我有一個很好的指標余辰年底要做多還做多他說做空YA 要漲囉
對
所以你要交好這些朋友
這些朋友很重要
常常保持聯繫
對
問他說
你有沒有看這兩個股票很不爽
我最喜歡我的製作人了
看得越不爽越容易感到
好
那走到這兩個時間
年底到3月初
股東會強制回補的高峰期
對不對
6月到8、9月年中會個除全息的強制回補
所以這兩個時期的軋空股特多
特多
對 因為到後面不得不補啊
對
你一定得補上去
好
但是呢 我一直記得你給我這個
嗯
就是我給你很多糖
待會 待會 待會會講到這一張
好
所以現在來公布
也考考觀眾好了
學了那麼多
辨別一下哪些是真嘎空股
哪些是假嘎空股
OK 好
辨別一下 這張等一下再開
好 先來辨別大考試
好 現在大考試
現在本節目因為走教學路線
到大考試
來看第一個
我來看
嗯
主力大賣
龍券投降
你寫出答案來了
誰做爛手辦
好 因為這個還是現在盡情事
好
所以他已經嘎到不能再嘎了是嗎
好 你看一下喔
融資在這裡大量增加喔
上漲融資增加
最有的是會被鼓吹造成的
對
然後呢 融券在這裡
我看他不爽
對
可是你看主力在這邊幹嘛
在賣
對
主力在賣 他還是會嘎一段
沿著不靈上軌
但是
BUT
只要一離開
對
然後呢
融券一投降
對
各位啊
我懂你的意思了
他快要長到像
旱遜那樣的狀態了
對
快要不行了
因為他最近呢
他也沒有強制恢復嘛
對
那各位你只要記得喔
這種軋空股
只要資減
資減
資減就是融資已經賺過了
勸減
勸也減
勸減 對
投降了
只要是融資賺過了
融券投降了
行情也差不多了
喔
對 尤其再搭配主力賣超的話
所以其實小哥的意思是
前一陣子他就是有火拼的狀況嘛
對不對
火拼 所以它會一路嘎上去
但是現在主力已經嘿嘿
賺寶下車 主力在跑喔
龍圈投降了
龍圈一直火拼下去 那可能會一直漲
那龍圈只要一投降 不完了
不完了 它就容易跌下來
所以它反而是嘎到極限
可能啦 大家觀察
可能要下跌了
這時候再去踹它 也沒有一定啦
因為搞不好後面之後龍圈又看它不爽又進去了
又被嘎了
因為講完我就想那我去放空啊
因為我就攔料了
對
我跟你講這還是在3的左邊
喔 還沒有真正往下跑
對 你就等月線下彎
月線下彎你要怎麼空就怎麼空
列入觀察
可能軋空接近尾聲的股票
是長這個樣子
好 那還有呢
來看這一檔
這一檔
好 他沿著上軌
他的勸資比高
對 限制比
等等 限制比高就是一個軋空的象徵
對不對
然後他還沿上軌上去
那就是典型的軋空股才對
那你在看主力在幹嘛
買
恐怖啦
這種千萬別空
千萬別空啊
他也在軋你啊
對 這種恐怖
我們看到絕對不會去空他
這還會軋到哪裡
他已經漲一段了
不知道不知道 不知道漲到哪裡
這個沒上車也不要上車了
對
因為沒上車搞不好
所以是快到最終點了
那有上車的 恭喜你
但是目前看了還在嘎
還在嘎
它是一檔嘎空股
好 再考一檔
再考一檔
對
這個大成鋼
券資比高會不會被嘎
我看看啊
欸 它沒有算漲很多耶
沒有什麼漲啊
然後融資是在減耶
融券其實也在減
對不對
主力其實也沒什麼著目
就是比好高啊
可是我覺得
可是它高格都在減
這應該不會渴
應該不會渴
好
這行情怎麼樣不知道
但是呢
這個券之比高
對
它不是用來渴的
那它是用來
它是拿來套利的
呵呵呵
為什麼叫套利呢
因為它有辦憲政
喔
對啊
辦憲政我就先放空嘛
對
我放空完之後呢
在低檔
對
不用抵擋
發了股票之後
我就做現券償還就好了
這就是另外一門功課
我們下次再來講
有辦現金增資的公司
我們怎麼股票套利好不好
小哥我幫你想好一集
不錯
你這講完
我們在後面再混什麼呢
早就好不好
上課的內容都被你講光了
沒辦法
理財達人秀就是號稱佛心
以後誰來上我們的課
我跟你講誰來上你的課好不好
就是因為散戶聽一次
絕對聽不懂
聽兩次也聽不懂
聽50次可能才會聽到
好像真的有動靴
所以我們第一次來這邊聽
後面49次去找你
好像蠻多這種的
好像也不錯
對 好 好 好 好
那不錯
所以是不是它不是軋空股
它是套利股
對
所以這三檔裡面只有一檔
其實還算是軋空股對不對
我們來揭曉啦
其實就是好展啦
登登 大家有沒有猜對咧
研究一下
它可能是正在走軋空行情的股票
但是不是叫你買喔
不要追啊
自己觀察我們今天教你的心法
好 那我們現在要來宣傳一件事情
登登登登登登登登登登
好 放在這邊好了
什麼事情咧
我們從11月2號禮拜一開始
我們的理財大連秀變成電視上
天天都會有喔
如果你是小哥的鐵粉
我們剛才已經在凹他了
1到5 小哥至少要來兩天吧
是不是
吐出一口鮮血
來一天
哪一天都有點痛苦
來兩天
好不好
錄影是快樂的
錄影非常快樂
看到我是開心的
很開心
對 錄影前很痛苦
那個晚上都廢了
別這樣
晚上都要開始準備這些東西
還好啦 那現在就
一個禮拜廢兩天嘛
禮拜一到禮拜五
東貞財經台57台
晚上8點到8點半
好不好 如果你支持我
也許你會看到更長更久的趙華
好不好 出行先看8點到8點半
還有第二點就是我們的
這個事情都不好意思啦
貪財貪貪我們之前有100塊的基因班
但如果你想看小哥的話
都是300塊的榮耀班
那非常謝謝大家的支持
因為我們希望給老師更好的教學品質
所以我們100塊的基因班
接下來在11月11號就會沒有囉
沒有囉
他還是有100塊的一個報名的窗口
那就是純怎麼樣
斗內給我們理財單秀好不好
斗內給趙華的用心
給達人的用心
但之後我們只有榮耀班
我們一律會升等
麻煩也升等
升等到300塊榮耀班
就可以繼續看我們小哥囉
那等一下我們也會再加入一段小哥的榮耀班
就是用全正教你賺軋空行情
那今天的理財單秀小哥又在趙華的逼供
言行考打下
吐出了到底軋空股怎麼操作
小哥講年底喔
年底到年初是最多軋空行情的時候
現在已經快賣入11月12月了
所以你可以好好的準備把這個學起來
坐在上面上漲空間是無限的
你可以看到別人吐血身亡
而且小哥是用他的血語類上了這堂課
因為他也被嘎爆闊
好 那今天理財達秀就到這邊囉
我們下次再見了 掰掰
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive